[Musique]
alors donc voilà donc il a mis ça maître
Gims et est-ce que vous comprenez la
polémique puisque derrière la précédente
de l'association Action protection
animale la APA donc Anne-Claire
Chauvency félicitations Gims la place
des animaux sauvages ni derrière les
barreaux ni dans les bras d'humain
s'afficher de la sorte avec une telle
notoriété c'est faire passer un message
dans heureux dans heureux
l'association One Voice elle est mort un
bébé félin bien loin de sa mère vous
participez au trafic d'animaux sauvages
honte à vous il y a campus animaliste
tout n'est que maltraitance monsieur
Gims avec ce comportement qui peut
sembler anodin je vous encourager
inconsciemment le trafic d'animaux la
place d'un animal sauvage n'est pas dans
les bras d'un humain mais dans la nature
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez oui non moi
je suis pas choqué moi j'en ai marre
qu'on tape sur Gims et surtout qu'à
chaque fois c'est avec des vidéos de 10
secondes cet animal on sait pas d'où il
vient on sait pas s'il a été abandonné
on sait même pas si c'est le sien il y a
plein voilà des animaux il y en a plein
dans les eaux dans les cirques personnes
ne dis rien et il y a plein de gens qui
seraient très contents et qui le font en
voyage de faire des vidéos avec des
bébés animaux surtout que sur la vidéo
en tant que tel il n'y a pas de
maltraitance du moins il y en a que moi
que sur d'autres vidéos qu'on voit ou
même pour tous les animaux qu'on tue
pour les manger au quotidien donc stop
l’hypocrisie et arrêter de taper sur
Gims juste qu'est-ce que c'est un mec
qui réussit qui est de l'argent
sur les réseaux sociaux
la moindre des choses dans ces cas-là
c'est si tu penses que ça peut susciter
les interrogations et que tu es dans ton
bon droit mais le contexte explique
peut-être qu'effectivement si cet animal
est dans un contexte de d'animal qui a
été récupéré parce que sa maman a été
tuée ou autre t'explique
tu sais très bien que il a il a
énormément de gens qui le suivent et
notamment des gamins comme l'a écrit il
aurait fait n'importe quoi tout le monde
elle est magnifique justement
mais justement valent ce que tu es en
train d'encourager c'est le fait qu'on
doit tout justifier et c'est
insupportable donc moi je crois pas
qu'il a justifié quoi que ce soit il a
pas la réputation d'être bête il est
assez intelligent donc je pense pas
oui
chacun notre avis ça se trouve il savait
lui-même qui disait des grosses
conneries mais pour la promotion de son
single on sait pas on connaît pas les
vérités de tout ce qui est dit sur les
réseaux ou quoi que ce soit donc au jeu
de juge pas l'histoire des pyramides là
si je juste cette histoire là il a pas
la réputation d'être bête donc s'il l'a
fait c'est qu'il l'assume totalement
[Rires]
je lève la main depuis tout à l'heure
depuis le début de l'émission pour
donner mon avis j'ai pas la parole si je
la prends et que vous foutez de ma
tronche
son entretien la semaine prochaine
vous inquiétez pas regardez là regardez
faites un plan sur elle regardez-la bien
vous risquez de ne plus la voir
le caracal c'est menacé c'est chassé
pour en faire des trophées il y a un
trafic en plus Cyril ça coûte de 2500 à
9000 €, ils sont trafiqués ces petits
animaux c'est très triste donc là c'est
pas bien ce qu'il fait parce que ça va
donner l'envie à des gens d'acheter un
Caracal et ça il faut pas laisser
tranquille
il passe par l'essent par exemple et le
vent sur Internet
et en fait ça arrive à l'aéroport les
douaniers même qui contrôlent ne peuvent
rien faire parce que comme ils sont tout
petits ça passe pour un chat et ça passe
comme ça avec le certificat d'un chat
voilà d'accord très bien merci merci il
a répondu en fait moi je trouve ça pas
bien parce que elle est toute mignonne
donc c'est ça il a mis une vidéo en
posant une nouvelle vidéo
dans sa voiture avec un petit message
ironique sur ces dernières polémiques le
saviez-vous le caracal descend
directement du Sphinx de Gizeh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà et donc là il assume il assume je
sais pas Guillaume par exemple parce que
tu peux dire là parce que là en
l'occurrence donc il compte il persiste
les signes
dans ma belle voiture je suis avec mon
père
en l'occurrence dans ma voiture regardez
je n'ai rien à de ce que oui
l'espèce protégée elle est là alors
qu'elle devrait être en pleine nature je
suis désolé d'avoir des animaux sauvages
chez lui il y a plein de gens qui font
l'amour
c'est qu'on lui tombe dessus comme
c'était le pire des criminels de la
vraie maltraitance animale on tue les
animaux il y en a tous les jours et
personne on va commencer par vous moi
de la viande il y a plein de gens qui
ont des animaux chez eux même en eux non
mais c'est vrai moi la semaine dernière
je regardais les oreilles du chat j'ai
les douaniers ils ont pris ça pour un
chat
en fait
[Rires]